uh
welcome back to the 2014 u.s
championship then u.s women's
and
women
we're puzzling over the
maurice and i are looking at the game
of a kobe and he has sacrificed a piece
um
and maurice and i were debating
um whether or not it was going to be a
perpetual check or could var continue
to fight for a victory what when we left
it we left it in this position
anticipating the move b7 b6 in fact that
wasn't played knight takes d4 bang
knight takes d4 queen takes h2 check
and now king f3 so maurice and i on
during our break were
wondering about pardon me perpetual
checks queen h5 check
and i was saying well what about maurice
what about queen takes d2 why does it
have to end in the perpetual check and
you were saying okay but white now one
wins upon knight takes e6 but
black had won two pawns a d4 pawn and h2
pawn
and
we were getting into this position and
it's
an awkward position
to judge because it's
it's tough i mean there's just a lot of
moves for both sides and i don't know
who stands better
and this is the position on the board
right now
no this was our analysis i i think our
last move
was actually king f2
uh king
f2 f3 and i was looking at queen takes
d2 knight takes e6
that was the where where i was going
with the analysis
and again i'm just looking at this
because this is a weird line to me let
me show you what i'm i'm looking at uh
jen
i'm thinking about this pawn on d4
right and if we saw
a move for argument's sake i'm just
going to throw something around like
this just wondering if this pawn
can go far or not
i got ideas
dirty dirty ideas evil intentions
don't know this is a
this is a funny line
and again it all depends if var believes
that he's better
uh
and or should he go for a perpetual
check
and we've got another uh sacrifice alert
here wow let's take a look at the
ramirez game wow
maurice is saying take a look at a rook
sack ooh
a rook sacrifice temporary rick
sacrament
a
sham sacrifice
so we got this position when we left it
rook h6 rook d2 now removing the
defender so that
if it were captures on h2 king takes d5
and it's it's just
totally it's a similar kind of a swap
uh to the one i i thought might happen
you might want to try kimby's i think
this is a draw
you might
well it's one of those things it's funny
jen
sometimes
the king can be a very good attacking
piece and you know you kind of put your
king down over here on a7
and again i'm sure the game's going to
be a draw but it's nice
from white's point of view that the
pawns on b7 and a6 are
are
are targets
um
so rook takes h2
let's see we could give a rook check
king has to go back
and we have some results in from the
women's championship anna zatonski has
won against tatev
and we expected that right and then you
can nimkova made a draw
right that was the bishops of opposite
color game somebody's got a couple more
games going on the women's and quite a
lot of heated battles in the jamb engine
right
so is there anything that white can do
to take advantage of black's king how's
this for a line
we're just looking at rook takes h2 rook
d6 how about this check king here king
here
with the idea of
mate
right
and if you go check what i want to do is
i want to hide my king
on a7
well that's a fun idea no that's a nice
one right okay
so we got this after rook h2
rook d6 check you can't go king c5
because of
you just get me right away i work at d5
you're right hockey mike we're going two
to d5 right check better pick the right
one right exactly otherwise you got to
do push-ups
so rook d6 jack you have to drop back
with your king
rook check now here
maybe you should not drop back with your
king king the c8 maybe is not
remember the rook is hanging
so you've got to keep contact with this
rook
right so you're saying instead of king
c8 you want to
you want to play king c6 well i'm not
sure um and then after rook g6
after rook on 2 to d6 jack king c5 and
rook d5 is no longer mate because you
needed to kind of do a switcheroo there
with the rocks right
but on the other hand i've got
other ideas now basically
on b4 kind of forcing if you take with
the rook
i think i just went around exactly so
i'm gonna have to and you have to
instead play king c4 that's uh what we
would call box but then then you have
mug another mate yeah so this is uh
this might work out no problem
so
you're saying that your line is forced
then with king c8 instead but there was
one check that you threw in there is
there any other so after rook d7 check
so this is the game gameplay
king c7 rook d7 check um king c6 and
king c8 so after king c8 you were saying
uh what about king bc so now um we don't
have to play
you gotta trade rooks okay yeah yeah
right and then after
yeah because you were looking at
something different here right
well i was just saying
no i was just saying that because of the
threat of checkmate
um i think we have to play rook takes d2
rook takes d2 and
i was trying to do this
evil idea of playing king to a7 and
somehow chasing your king away from the
protection of the pawn on b7 well you
could also check on before which would
keep an eye on the b7 pawn
instead of checking on f6 okay so you'd
have a second defender
with the kind of an awkward square for
the rook but
at the moment getting the job done right
that's exactly right so still probably a
draw
but god is now the one who's
investigating his chances whether he has
the upper hand
yes and the two are two really exciting
games this round we still
we we uh we have a a move from daniel
and eric get its key against josh
riddell but first we have something from
maurice on the
campsite game
just some little tidbits on that game
guys this maneuver by kamsky really
doesn't work
rook check and then king back to c7 and
now rook d7 check king c6 is actually
quite playable why because after rook
check king up b4 looks like it's winning
you mentioned that lion king c4 would
get it mated well he could just play
rook takes and after this check
two moves
king c6 is one
just keeping an eye no sorry my fault
after after this move rook to
rook to d4 check
uh he can play the move king to c3 sorry
play king c3 and now when you take the
rook take a look at this tactic rook
takes check attacking your king and now
and you don't want to move away because
you lose your rook and if you play this
move in this sweet little move b6 check
and you've got to give the rook back and
the game ends in a draw so little tiny
tactics no doubt kamsky is calculating
carefully before he walks into this line
and actually decided that it wasn't
worth it and so he's just simply traded
rooks and it's beginning to look
a lot like a draw
a hard fought draw for sure
um
and gotta i think will be
um pleased that he didn't lose this game
after i i'll bring
you back to the other game that i'm
finding fascinating
between naraditsky as white against josh
friedel we just saw that defensive
retreat queen e8 by josh setting up a g6
captures h5 check type of capture uh
threat
and
daniel
went queen h3 with his own
uh
ideas
involving um g takes eight uh h takes g6
and queen h a check
and rookie seven mating and rook h7
mating so uh
at the moment this pawn on c2 is very
good but that's not the that's not the
important trump in the position the
question is
uh is black's king um
now do we have
not played with our our past c pawn to
consider something like taking on h5
followed by f5 check giving off that
pawn but just you know aiming to play
let's see so g takes and in case what
you're saying is in case of queen takes
h5
f5 i'm trying to play this move yeah
absolutely and of course we're giving up
a pawn there but i'm trying to get rid
of some of the heat here right so you
can't take with a rook because of uh our
queen right um so instead taking with
the king and now what's the story here
we're actually even on pawns right right
but the king again that king g6 is
looking kind of nasty with f7 jack so
um yes you're preventing that with king
f7 but now
um so you're renewing some threats here
with rook h7 check
but meanwhile
i also gotta watch c1 a little bit all
the time all the time
but uh i kind of feel that uh
white's pleased that he's getting this
kind of counter play it's like black
wanted to win smoothly and cleanly and
all the rest of that and he's not
getting an easy victory out of this one
for sure oh although i wonder what the
threat is here exactly because rook 87
we can drop back to e8 right without
immediate disaster oh sure so what about
like i mean i'm looking i'm trying to
play a move like rook c3 and rook takes
b3 and then a2 and bishop a3 right try
to win oh absolutely let's give that
that
a look-see
i was thinking that knight c1
if you go this way rook
f3 right because you're you want to stop
me from playing moves like f7 and you
want to
try to pick up this pawn i'd get behind
the pawn
now you're also getting counter play
with ca check as well
well i was dreaming i know it's a
terrible dream that if i could ever get
my knight to e5
it would be a mate rook c8
would be a sweet little mate i'm picking
up a tempo but i do believe that this is
asking too much
from the position but it just goes to
show it's not all play on one goal
it's not all one
but
but that move what you said um
f5 check in case of queen takes h5 i'm
just wondering if donya shouldn't
uh let black
um
just play
um with the queens on the board how
about this retreat king g3
i do have the idea that in case of rook
check i've got f3
and the pawn on h5 is a goner anyway so
an interesting idea there and
we've got something from maurice ashley
in one of the remaining games in the u.s
wins championship
yes jen it's raining pawns in the
miliquina foyzer game it looks like
black is going to win with ease in this
position she played the tremendous move
e3 the bishop is pinned obviously to
this rook so big trouble for white in
this position she played rook takes on
g6 that made things even worse because
of this monster move rook to f8 now this
bishop is caught in a cross pin and is
going down after the move rook to g5
check the king
just dominating in the e4 square in the
middle of the board and now the move
rook to f5 but that move is definitely
not going to help because of rook takes
f5 pawn takes and now the monster move
d3
and truly just a crushing position
pawns down the board rook king dominant
position it looks like foyzer is going
to reel this one in a real save for her
and she's going to stay on a perfect
score here at the u.s women's
championship back to you jen and yes
and wizards hadn't had a lot of great
success in this championship so
very exciting for her to start out plus
two yeah talk about a confidence boost
there's nothing like a victory to make
you feel good in and this one as well i
mean okay the first game that you won in
round one that was a really really fine
game this one
she got fortunate on
but
great great to win these types of games
where your pawns just go all the way up
the board and like space invaders you
know
press your opponent back
i'm looking at the game between mack and
okobian and that looks like it's going
towards a repetition a perpetual check
that came
about to be wrapped up as a draw
lenderman
we haven't seen the game between
lenderman and gary evan a while let's
get an update on that
because that has been an exciting day
and my goodness
garyv
he's
he's playing for the win
my goodness how did that happen
let's go back a few moves
we thought he was in trouble
but look at that the fighting king
so when we left it we had left it there
was just this queen sacrifice
and i suspect
when
lenderman played the move e5 check
he has missed something for example like
d takes e5 maybe yeah because this
position
has no longer turned favorable at all
like before you play the move e5 check
you know you know you don't suddenly say
oh i'll trade that position for this
position
where it's blacks black
who
can target white's pawn structure
and suddenly
garriev was a pawn up
and it sure looks to me that
garyv
is
uh closer to winning
than lenderman is to drawing so it looks
like a position that garyv
is going to pull out his win
very interesting indeed
and we have four-time u.s women's
champion anna zadonski and she's with
grandmaster ashley to talk about her win
against one of the highest rated players
in the event actually in the number
three rating tactic of rahamian
indeed in a big match up in round two
already between two of the fema the
favorites in the event we call them uh
two and a half what did i call them
yesterday two and a half
horses that's what it was i didn't i
didn't come up with a phrase someone
else did they said the two and a half
horse race and and then i upgraded her
to a full horse but now you've
downgraded her back yeah to a half of
her so a a tough
game for her but congratulations on your
victory yeah thank you now was were you
better throughout the game was it was it
a smooth one or a real fight no it was a
real fight but i think most of the game
i was better and i got some
initiative after opening at least what i
thought and
she had a lot calculate a lot in order
to find best moves and i think she
played pretty good and just some
mistakes by the end of the game now you
mentioned that she was in time pressure
how severe was the time pressure
i'm not sure i think something like two
minutes four five seven moves something
like that but i was also in term
pressure but not that severe and
it was so easy for me to play have clear
plan and she had to find defense so for
me it didn't matter so
indeed uh the
game yesterday was a really hard fought
game on your part and you you had to
make a draw and when you knew it was a
draw it was still another hour to play
how did you recuperate so easily from
yesterday to be able to play such a
powerful game today actually yesterday i
was never losing i thought my position
was pretty bad but then i checked with
computer and that was always fine it was
worse of course but it was never losing
it's
nothing but okay it just uh it was so
big choice for me so i had to decide
which opening to play and
like i i like i said uh already to you
that uh if i'm playing e4 i if i have to
fight with my husband because he's the
four player and
he always think i should play d4 and
so you played e4 today yeah you won yeah
but i was pretty strict that i want to
play e4 and this is it yeah and he
helped me yes he helped me a lot so even
if he his default player and i tried to
relax i watched moving and um
just kept your head clear yes yes so now
there is a bit of news which doesn't
pertain to you at the moment now that
was announced that the bobby fischer
prize has now been extended to the
women's section wow i didn't know
so this is just this was just announced
yeah you had to tell me before the game
yeah yesterday yeah i'm sorry buddy
you're breaking my heart
it was only announced today we didn't
know either it was announced in the
middle of the broadcast don't want to
get you down but then it should be like
after our first round so it should be 8
out of 8.
maybe you're gonna have to petition rex
for that one
uh what you you now are in a good
situation of course your main rival has
two points
you guys have been through this so often
uh it's either you or her you her you
or tatif yeah don't forget we played
match for the first first place indeed i
mean she did come in once but you guys
have won nine uh championships together
and now we said taking a bit of a step
back maybe a real challenge for her
what has this rivalry been like for you
to to be
this they're classic rivalries in sports
you know whether it's federer and a doll
or bird magic red sox
against the yankees there's some classic
rivalries and sports yours is a special
uh in this u.s championship the u.s
women's championship where you guys have
gone back and forth what has it been
like for you to be a part of this
rivalry um
i don't know before
or somehow i i could get like motivated
but now it's so slightly different and
it's it's really hard to put like all
energy
into this game
i was trying my best and um
i don't know we played many games and uh
definitely right now she played a lot
and uh like your result was better than
mice so it's i will try my best i will
try to get motivated and i will try to
find
the way to get angry or something yeah
you were angry yesterday walking out of
here it seems like you took it on your
opponent today
oh was i angry yeah you never saw me
angry probably
i think you said you were angry
yesterday about it yeah i said yes
yeah and like maybe 20 years ago or 12
years ago sometimes i used to cry after
the game so it's like kind of normal and
now unfortunately i don't remember when
i cried last time after the chess game
yeah
the wow
an emotional game chess is and
congratulations on your win today and
good luck in the rest of this
championship
anna zatonski uh definitely strong in
mind strong in chess and her husband you
know
gotta listen when she puts her foot down
back to you jen and yes
nice nice so apparently we don't want to
see her angry no no no no no no just uh
we should wake up every morning and say
is anna happy that that that's very
important um where we do have on our
board right now a game that we've been
following between
mac and var
we've been expecting a kind of a
perpetual shack a repetition to occur in
that game and it has in fact happened so
the draw has been agreed in that
heartfelt
fight and i think we're going to have a
chat with some of those players as well
wonderful
and let us just see with godakamsky once
again
what has transpired after that
and it does look indeed like they're
going to get that rook ending that we've
been looking at where white manages to
get his king all the way to a7 this is
the current position on the board i
would anticipate a line of play that
would go like this
where
only two results are possible really a
draw or a white victory this white king
sitting on a7 can be very annoying
um
but assuming that uh alejandro doesn't
misplace
miss play this game it should be a draw
agreed yeah i think we'll see a draw on
that game and then
for now of course is extremely exciting
and rich
sure they only recently made move 40
just a few moves ago ah and we saw the
and i imagine they're probably going to
get into the uh the time pressure again
actually because these moves uh are all
so fraught um in fact after queen to h3
we were discussing different defensive
options for black and black ended up
playing this move bishop h6 wow
i think probably with the idea that
taking on g6 can be met by
probably f5 check though
so f4 was dania's choice but i mean the
simple question to ask is do we have
time to capture on
um
g6 and threaten this bishop i think
there's this clever
little move f5 check
and we can't do amp assant because of
queen takes g6 check and suddenly this
c1 queen is going to win the game for
josh
so
that was why dania played f4
bishop had to drop back to g7 because
now taking on g6 was a serious threat
and i guess we're up to date yeah but
we're up to date now after
after 44 bishop g7 and both players have
about a little over 10 minutes on the
clock and what move number is this 44 or
so
and for the time control is to move 60
yes
yeah
okay well at certain point it's kind of
now or never
danya has to say well shouldn't i be
taking this pawn on g6 if the pawn is
recaptured
after it takes on g6 takes on g6 how's
this for strange looking variation
attacking with the king queen h7
check king f7 i got to stop the c1 kind
of stuff
knight c5
funny idea of maybe
hoping hoping that this move rook g rook
h6 might land
and deliver some goods it's unclear
um
who stands better at this point but we
do have in our studio
one of the players who just finished
their game that's right we've got a
newcomer to the championship and uh we
had his former coach on earlier michael
korkowski right so grandmaster mackenzie
mullner starting the us championship
with two hard-fought draws
he's with maurice ashley
indeed i'm with grandmaster mackenzie
mullner first of all congratulations on
your two on your draw today thank you
uh first time in the u.s championship uh
what did you expect and and has that uh
expectation been met
well i expect it to be really really
challenging i have never played a
tournament where this many good players
all in a row there's a
no easy games that's for sure so
it's it's been tough so far i had some
chances today so i thought you know
maybe i could get off to a nice start
with these two whites but
uh i guess i'm i kind of slipped up
somewhere and
i was happy with the draw though well
you played two of the tougher players in
the tournament for sure and ona's chuck
and jacobian they're they're veterans in
this field
what was wrong today what do you think
you could have done better
well
uh ocobian suggested that i instead of
taking on f5 with the bishop that i
actually take with the knight and then
put my bishop on h5 and just kind of
clog things up a little bit for him on
the king side and
keep keep like maybe some long-term
pressure rather than i was thinking
about trying to attack that's kind of
usually what i'm thinking about it's
your ammo isn't it right
uh yeah so that was more on my mind and
but yeah i kind of i probably could have
been a little bit more patient that
would have been a good idea now the
opening was really dramatic i mean you
play this idea of knight e1 and f g4 f4
if you don't mind just throwing it up
there for us uh right here i'll just do
it right here
uh this moment i mean it was really
aggressive looking to win a piece you
you could have tried that and all what
was that this is this one this is what
you wanted right out of the opening yeah
something where i could definitely fight
uh my game yesterday was i was going for
some kind of like like a little bit of
an ambitious opening but it kind of
smooth like smoothed out too much and
today i just wanted something uh really
combative
and i thought about going for the piece
sacrifice but i didn't think it would
quite work out so well so yeah we didn't
like it so much either uh
for for white
uh you're we had your former coach or
current coach or
or or maybe just just an advisor and a
mentor now uh michael karkovsky on
what's the relationship been like with
him and how's he supported you doing
this tournament
well uh we actually working together a
little bit before the tournament started
he was sending me some training problems
and doing whatever he could to help
which i really appreciate
um
and i haven't talked to him a ton during
the tournament but it's nice to have him
here it's you know it's always nice to
have friendly faces around and makes you
know playing the first first time at the
u.s championship a little bit easier
when you know you have some close
some close people around indeed and a
closing thought about the chess club
itself have you ever been here and
what's it been like to to to be treated
so royally regally here in the tesla
it's awesome it's it's the nicest place
to play that i've ever gone to
i uh i'm not used to the cameras or
anything like that but just you know the
conditions are fantastic it's a great
tournament and uh i even was thinking
about the the crepes restaurant down the
street before i got here so i like
pretty much everything about uh st louis
well we look forward to the rest of your
games in slashing attacking style
hopefully best of luck in the rest of
the tournament thank you grandmaster
mackenzie mullner uh off to a very good
start a lot of players would uh love to
draw onus chuck and a copy in the first
two rounds of their very first u.s
championship back to you jen and jazz
great and more excitement to call them
surely more crepes as well so surely
more crepes i saw that we had a result
it looked to me right sabina foytre has
officially defeated elizabeth right the
ponds carried the day
uh in that match up
um
a nice turnaround for foiser as sabine
sabine is
when she comes down
she's going to be heartened by the news
of the bobby fischer prize for the
women's championships
you want to make a bet
oh i'm sure she'll be pretty excited
about it okay i win
any other games what other games do we
have we have camille i see on our screen
we have camilla
and
victoria let me bring that game
up on our screen it looks uh
oops
it looks like
a pawn for victoria upon a head
so
last few moves we're getting here
we see some trades and this pawn
two versus one
these night endings like king and
pontian games are are very very similar
to kingdom pawn ndms
but with the night of course you got the
opportunity to
sacrifice your night
um
for the pawns i'm i'm thinking this is
going to be more
leaning towards a draw
than a win
for
victoria but of course
black is better
one thing that she can't allow i'll just
put up one variation which would of
course be
very good for camilla this is what i
mean where you try to sacrifice your
knight for two pawns
but maybe maybe there's some chances
with the move knight d7
to try to win the game this is a winning
king and pawning game for
black
so there's no nitrate of course camilla
would never do that
she's much too of a
wily veteran
but um
if black at play f5
king b5
she might still have chances i'm not
sure
knight back
f5 again it's these night sacrifices all
you need to do is get rid of two pawns
that's right
to get that draw and she's that close so
it seems like our most excitement of the
day remaining is that uh nareditsky for
dell game and as we get our next guest
set up
let's take a brief peek at that because
a few more have been played and it is to
clarify this is the final time to draw
okay it's uh
two time controls right and then it's 15
minutes for the rest of 30 seconds 36.
oh you just play on increments you don't
even get a little bonus after move 60.
oh my okay
all right so we do have this situation
we go back a move or two
finally as i was mentioning you got to
play hg6 one day fg6
knight c5
queen f7
king f3 stepping back
so that you make
the attack against the pawn on e6
possible
you have ideas of knight takes e6
queen h7 you got to be careful though
about brook c3 this game is definitely
heating up
um
yeah i know right it can't it seems like
this could be the end of the first time
control but instead it's the seven that
kind of dropped exactly of course with
the 30 second increments
wow
uh
very very sharp position here i'm not
really too sure i
i think i'm favoring
black because this pawn on c2 could be
so disruptive
and black has even ideas of g5
so i do favor josh's chances
bishop doing a good job of defending as
well right yeah so i do i do favor
josh's position but it's not like uh he
had a good position a long long time ago
it's been that way
it's that's been the case for most of
the game
and i just don't like his technique
shall we say but we do have a
a perfect 2-0 in the u.s women's chess
championship and she's with grandmaster
maurice ashley
thanks and first of all congratulations
sabina on a hard fought game thank you
you were in a little bit of trouble in
this position tell us about it
i did not expect her to play um the
closest scene
sorry french with e5
and yeah this line i i didn't check it
at all and i didn't like my position i
just tried to get the pawn and defend
and
i thought it was okay until at some
point when she had the 96 and then
suddenly i didn't like my position
anymore and uh you gave away a piece in
that position i did because because i
thought that um if i if i were to play
knight c8 it should capture in g7 and
then queen e5 and i didn't really like
my position there and i thought okay
maybe i can just sacrifice the piece and
um you know i have a pretty compact pawn
structure and my king looked pretty safe
so i thought okay maybe i have some
chances to draw
there and um yeah then i was lucky then
she traded queens yeah that was a big
relief for you yeah i was i thought okay
after queens were were exchanged i
thought it probably will be at least a
draw so
but then you know i started pushing the
pawn so yeah wow i mean look at this how
often do you checkmate with pawns in
this fashion it doesn't happen uh too
many games
so you're so you're a 2-0 and we have
some big news some breaking news in fact
that the bobby fischer prize has been
extended to the women's section as well
okay so a 9-0 result could result in an
extra 64 000
what are your thoughts on that uh
development
i don't know i'll i still will play a
game at a time you know and see see what
what happens indeed you're one of uh
just i think only two women now who have
gone two and now so you're tied for
first with um with irina who had a
pretty
fairly easy game today but tomorrow you
face
a real champion a four-time champion in
anna zatonski what's your record with
her
i think maybe i made two draws out of i
don't know how many games we played so
mostly i'm i lost most of them you have
not defeated her yet no
indeed so so a very tough opponent for
you what do you think you have to do
differently to do well against her
tomorrow
i will just you know try to play a nice
game and we'll see the result you know
indeed well thanks so much for joining
us and good luck in the rest of your
games thank you so much a weary sabina
foyzer after a long and tough battle and
survival that's what it's about at the
u.s championships back to you jennings
nice
nice it's always good to start two and
zero in fact it's kind of a perfect
start
better than that can't do better than
that um
in this uh narrative ski fidelity and we
do have a move from josh okay he has
played g5 which we mentioned earlier as
one of the key moves
one of the reasons why this move g5 does
come at a very effective moment
obviously if white could play knight
captures e6 and queen h7 in a single
move it would be checkmate
so to set up
knight takes e6 the problem with knight
takes e6 a move that you would really
really like to play
under a lot of different conditions the
problem is not a queen
or anything like that but rather rook c3
check skewering the queen on h3 so dania
doesn't have the time to get in this
highly desirable move knight takes
knight takes uh e6
so
that not being available
after g5 he's got to come up with
something
um
better
simply than that and
and view of queen takes f4 check
though
can't allow queen takes f4 check
how about
king
e2
so you want to get
again i i i'm desperately trying to get
in this move knight takes e6 yeah
but i can't if i can't allow or can't
afford rook 8 rook c3 check so i'm
thinking that if i drop back with my
king i'm gonna i'm playing for cheapos
let's be honest i'm playing for cheapos
i'm playing and play knight takes e6 and
queen h7
okay
so
so i'm thinking king e2 of course you
cannot take with your queen
because then queen takes e6 as a check
so what do you think king e2
the best chance
kg little move the best chance
for and now if i um
how's the sacrificing t5 looking
probably good for you
yeah and i'm trying to play
i see that when i play queen takes f4
now i still got this oh yeah that's true
yeah
and then you could take like this with
the idea that one day you would take
with the bishop and you'll have
four
connected past fawns
uh so that rook takes c5 typo or i could
try to play f3 and bishop h6 and you
can't take on h6 because of c1 queens
uh-huh
so the exchange sacrifice is uh
definitely a chance but
you know i've got a feeling that
white's
still kicking here it's not it's not
over
it's not over at all
okay
so has that
has uh king e2 been seen
i don't see another move
king g2
that king e2 looks kind of forcing
we do have a couple more moves here in
fact it looks like your move your move
uh
yeah 48 kg too king e21 and then g takes
f4 g takes f4 okay queen h7
hakasito oh he didn't play why didn't he
play knight takes e6
i thought daniel wanted to play knight
takes e6 okay but sorry he did play what
instead queen to h7 okay
king then after king f8 queen takes c2
okay that was important get rid of that
guy and now f3 okay
king f2
naturally and rook to b8 and that's our
current position
whoa
well dania's fighting very well here
while we um and actually we do have a
move um in response to the idea of rook
b2 rook b1 was played but while we're
puzzling out this madness okay we have
um alyssa malaquina
and she's with grandmaster maurice
ashley all right
indeed jen thank you
first of all alyssa thanks for joining
the show
thanks for having me now you had a very
difficult game you seem to have a
promising chance to win this game you
were up a piece at some point
what happened to cause it to go downhill
sure i was up a piece for two pawns and
i think it started earlier i wasn't
expecting her to sacrifice the piece at
that moment i was looking at king of
fate um but at this moment
i see that i made the mistake of trading
queens and i thought that here i would
have to trade queens because my bishop
is under attack and if i move the bishop
then
queen e4 is coming and she also has
mating threats i thought that after f4
she wouldn't be able to
go e5 and i could hold and you know i'm
up material so i thought this would be
the natural point to exchange pieces
right but you could have brought the
rook over instead of instead of trading
queens and you had a great attacking
position how is it
how does your mind shift when you're in
a good position all of a sudden it's
like
when did you realize you had gone wrong
in fact
um after king d6 and i realized that i
couldn't stop c5 and e5 from coming i
think even later on i shouldn't have
taken the bishop on c6 because that
was really her only chance to get the
pawns rolling but i
underestimated how powerful that was and
here the reason i didn't go rook d1 and
protect the bishop was because
i thought she would take on b5 then i
would lose another pawn and i missed
that after
f5 e5 i could take on e5 with the bishop
indeed i might might as well show that
line uh
here
if she takes
takes
takes then this move is
indeed really powerful
after queen takes so a difficult start
to the championship this is not your
first rodeo though uh you've been here
before how do you bounce back from a
tough loss when you're playing in the
championship
sure well it's important to realize that
this is
a round robin so i'm still going to play
everyone and anything can happen and
just because i have a tough start
doesn't mean that i have to end that way
and just take it one game at a time one
opponent at a time
good attitude we know that you just
completed your law degree i believe i
did i just finished with my last finals
a few days before arriving
congratulations thank you
and you have a startup tell us about
that
i do i just launched a new business and
that's been occupying my time more than
law school recently
it's just an online startup it's a
portal for verified summer sublets
when i got summer internships i found it
hard to find housing usually people use
craigslist
but i realize that there needs to be a
network of just student-only sublets
so that's what we're doing and it's a
subscription model so we're going to
universities and offering the service
through them so what is the name of it
it's called sublight.net
sublight.net okay yeah so i've been
doing a lot of you know client calls
with universities and
that's also been occupying my time but
you know now i'm just focusing on chess
and
all industrious lady get your law degree
you got the online startup and you're
playing in the u.s women's championship
that can't all be easy to pull off
one last question i have to do for my
own personal benefit uh you're going to
be playing in the millionaire chess open
tell me your thoughts about that i am
i'm excited for that
after i take the bar
in late july i have two and a half
months off before i start working at my
firm in october so during that time i'll
be preparing and
looking forward to millionaire chess and
it's exciting to have another big stakes
tournament throughout the year because
the u.s championships are great but you
know they only happen once a year in may
and this way i have something to keep me
motivated and this is when
i study chess the most and where i keep
going with it
well i can't play any favorites as the
organizers so i can't wish you too much
of a good luck i guess i can say good
luck in that and good luck in the rest
of the championships
thanks so much alyssa melikina off to a
tough start but with the right attitude
she'll be bouncing back back to you
jenna yes
thank you osmari absolutely nice
well spoken i'm thinking to myself my
goodness
passing the bar
your own startup and playing in the
women's championship
um
is there any other challenges she wants
to take on
that's quite a simultaneous what do you
think jennifer
is a cyclist
yeah that's like that's like the iron
woman competition right you've got to do
you have got to have three careers
and everything else she's not a mommy
right no no that would be too much i
mean that would be too much to ask
some things have been happening in the
game in the match uh pardon me the game
between josh
and dania i think um we've gotten to the
position though
handshake it looks like that game has
been drawn right
a big save a big save by donya in this
game
let me just
bring the last moves into our screen so
we can go over them and
see
what has happened
right
so
when we had left it we had left it at
the
point of rook b8 so rook b8 had the
uh obvious threat of rook b2 skewering
the queen to the king
that was stopped rook b1 change
trade
there was this queen was coming to
be a check so the king had to make room
it went king g8
check
and a repetition
uh perpetual check repetition
i'm sure daniel will be very very
pleased to have escaped well speaking of
grave he has
didn't fight yesterday but today
he was forced it was actually happening
it looks like uh good things are
happening for him and his board exactly
so let's switch over to that game as we
wait for
naraditsuki and for now perhaps we get a
chance to chat with one or both of them
okay
so i'll just bring that game up in our
screen
whoa
let's see what had happened
here we are in the game between alex
linder and
timor have gone wrong for lender man oh
big time
when we were here
i had already thought that
timor was well on his way to winning
and he sacrificed in exchange
got his b-pawn going this bishop is just
beautifully covering the promotion of
this h-pawn in the meanwhile
black's king is going to escort
his b-pawn
which indeed is what i believe is
we're in this position
so let's just see
okay yes that's where we're at we're at
rook h1
okay so we're anticipating queen
trade
trade and casca ramirez is officially a
draw
so let's just move over cabsie couldn't
squeeze any any blood from that a rookie
two verse four can do
i'm just realizing that uh
um
lenderman's going to be in time to trade
his last um bishop b5 you just uh
play h7 and distract my bishop huh right
and then i and one move too slow
exactly
yeah i need one more move right
my kingdom for a tempo
so let's just see where it does look
like he's made a queen
okay so that and lenderman immediately
recapturing i think he's
okay so this was all this
this was our main line
now i played the move king here
i played bishop h8 i didn't know
where else i was supposed to put my
bishop
and that was the line we just
saw
where it was the tempo
and we went here and i went back with my
bishop
it does is there some so you're thinking
maybe bishop a1 there's another move
i don't think it made a difference
because i still have to go after i still
have to protect my pawn on c7
so
i'm
really surprised maybe
maybe timor
did not win
this
position in the most
effective manner especially if he
doesn't win bringing out the next
scoresheet for move 60.
we're seeing plenty of moves in this
championship 83 moves yesterday by a
swan
nice nice
so h
maybe it was here because i sure have
the feeling that
that black should be winning after h5
i'm thinking about the move bishop c3
why didn't gary f play bishop c3
good point
you know maybe he miscalculated that
variation we just looked at
boy but he's so good in his calculations
one of the greatest
blindfold players i've ever seen
uh playing 33 boards simultaneously and
calculating oh yeah
and for him not to calculate which looks
like a very straightforward
uh line of play
um you say he could calculate this
blindfold
and simultaneously i guarantee you
he could calculate a blindfold
and again this line just i don't see
how
timor can deviate from a variation that
would just end in a draw
so i'm anticipating a draw in this game
and a big big save by lenderman
and timor will be upset with himself
although at some point remember in this
topsy-turvy game we actually preferred
lenderman's position oh big time it's
gone a see-saw battle oh
throughout yeah and
that remarkable king g6 move by
garyv wow walking into it so to speak
and he has played bishop h8 so they're
following our analysis
but
not much to be done here king takes f4
and white's king just
goes around the horn
after capturing this pawn white's king
will make
a quick march and linderman playing very
quickly and competently we wasting no
time
showing this variation on the board that
the only other game we have going at the
time is uh being striking so
these two final games going on in the
u.s championship
breaking the 60 move mark
right
and again this is just the whole forcing
and we have in our studio joining us
he's getting ready he's getting ready
ramirez ali alejandra a runner-up from
last year right it's with maurice ashley
to talk about his critical battle today
against godakamsky
indeed with last year's runner-up to the
championship alejandro ramirez first of
all welcome to the show
well thank you second um
you seem to have got his number i mean
maybe it's a bit much just overstating
it but this guy is a four-time u.s
champion you know you're not supposed to
be drawing him this many games how did
you how are you having such good results
against him well if it were after me he
would have only been three-time u.s
champion
indeed
you know it was interesting because i
saw some of his games and i
i thought he would not expect a french
even though i've played it before
and
you know he always likes to switch it up
a little bit when he's faced with
something unexpected and he played the
advanced variation which he's never done
in his life
and actually had predicted that he would
probably do this
so i had i analyzed something and it was
quite interesting and i actually got a
better position out of the opening it
looked that way yeah so i was pretty
happy and at some point i was actually
playing for the win
but at some point i messed it up and
actually had to
you know be a little careful to draw the
end
this guy
knows how to defend a little bit doesn't
he you know it's really annoying because
it's it's not that she's just defending
it seems that every move that he does oh
at the same time he defends his position
he also threatens something so he
doesn't give you any peace of mind to
actually continue an attack or build up
your position it was an interesting game
i think i was better for the majority of
it maybe not not much
but i mean it was it was interesting so
how do you feel about your start is two
two draws uh starting out uh i mean it's
all right okay i didn't want to draw
white my first white especially the way
that it was i felt that my opponent got
a draw relatively effortlessly
so that was not so great but okay it's a
draw not at the end of the world and
then okay i draw kamsky on the second
round with black so so far so good
st louis what can you say about a city
like this now the capital of chess in
america no it's well deserved i mean
st louis has come
far far away from what it used to be in
terms of uh
chess i remember many tournaments that i
played years ago
in in st louis specifically that okay
maybe i would show up maybe another
grandmaster and they'll be about it this
is before the st louis chess club even
existed and you see now i mean you can
have hordes of grandmasters in this in a
tournament
yeah you you think you could walk into a
starbucks and you'd be the strongest guy
there and you might be wrong no i i
would i wouldn't put money on it indeed
one final thought you're playing in the
millionaire chess open uh in
october what are your thoughts about
this event well i'm looking forward to
it i mean i like the player list so far
because so far i think i have a
guaranteed price so
i mean
of course they will get a lot more
grandmasters and it'll be quite a tough
competition i've heard rumors of people
that wanted to
register so we'll see at the end how it
uh turns out well we look forward to
welcoming you at that event i think
you're uh guaranteed a limousine ride
from the airport so that should be fun
well i'll take it well best of luck in
the rest of the championship thank you
grand master alejandro ramirez is uh
last year's runner-up
two draws to start off so not so bad
back to you jen and yes
and always winning and i was waiting i
was thinking of this comment that
alejandro and
going into a starbucks and you're not
sure that you're the strongest
grandmaster what happened was susan
pogar at the webster university and i we
had gone out to lunch
together and as we were walking
back
to the saint louis chess club
a group of webster university students
joined us
and then her son tom joined us and as
there was like 8 10 of us walking down
the street getting back to the saint
louis chess club and then suddenly tom
you know said this is terrible i'm the
only person in the group that's not a
grandmaster
because all the webster students on her
team were grand masters
i tell you it's a tough neighborhood
a whole old flock of grand masters well
perhaps grave is trying to
make up a little bit for yesterday that
it looks like they're playing to king
verse king in this game yes
and that would be a fitting way to uh
apologize
yes yes that is the kind of guy graham
is though he's like so i don't know
it's really interesting yeah well at
some point at the end of
what if the game ends we've gotta we've
gotta
uh tackle the players
and ask them what their opinions were
way back when
before that move e4 e5 was played
and whether white
had a superior
move
and before we get to that position this
is actually the position i thought
that was that was critical
uh
i was thinking maybe age three here
right i just had slow expansion and
that's slow
but we do have yet another guest uh
joining us
all right we have grand master daniel
naraditsky and he's with maurice ashley
about his fascinating battle today
thanks jen the youngest
player in the competition on the male
side grand master daniel naradiski
welcome to the show thank you daniel
boy you look like you were in trouble
this game i mean you look like you're
going to lose this game for so long you
mentioned that this moment in the game
was was a turning point in the opening
at least uh tell us about this this
setup yeah you know i was pretty happy
with the outcome of the opening and i
played the catalan just wanted to reach
a quiet position with a slight edge and
i thought i did but then i completely
overlooked this idea it's it's kind of
thematic b5 and if bishop takes b5 then
knight takes e5
and um okay perhaps i should have gone
for it but um
i i still you know i still thought i had
an edge i still couldn't believe that
i'd missed this
so i just exacerbated it with queen e3
and after he locked up my queen side it
became
very very difficult it looked ugly i
mean it just looked like black was
dominant i thought i was going to lose
in like five moves
i'm not that bad uh but then you fought
back yeah it was incredible seeing how
you just put trouble in his way you must
you're king of the board even to the g4
squad how did you feel about that when
it was happening uh really scared
obviously but
uh i figured that if i don't play g4 uh
you know
i don't want to just die sitting i want
to die fighting and uh you know i know
it's a cliche but i figured the only
possibility to cause them problems is to
create threats on the king side even if
they're not very serious and even if my
king is weaker than his
i thought if i just wait he'll he'll
eventually penetrate along the c file
and you know he has plenty of time he'll
just patiently outmaneuver me and i
really have no chance and after g4 it
was the incredible thing was that there
it was really not that easy for him no
there were some unbelievable tactics and
uh
yeah indeed we were checking in with the
computer too and we it wasn't that just
a rollover win yeah very interesting
ideas
so
uh you made a draw yesterday as well yes
right so now you've started off your
your first u.s championship with with
two drawers that's the second one oh the
second excuse me so i started the first
one as well oh okay how did that one end
up uh
okay i think i scored two and a half out
of seven but it was
that was the qualifiers one was it yeah
that was oh that's right that's right
okay it was a great experience maybe i i
lost the last two games
and it was pretty disappointing but
otherwise i
it was it was terrific so what were your
expectations coming into this one now
that you had one under your belt uh you
know obviously it's it's easier to
sort of acclimatize to this kind of
pressure and the cameras and and a lot
of people watching
um i i'm certainly not letting that get
to me as much
uh but of course it's still it's an
absolutely awesome event um i really
feel the need to play some good chess
you know when you have such respect in
such conditions and such strong players
uh and you know my goal my expectations
i just want to play as many good games
as possible again this is kind of this
is what everybody says
but uh i figure games like this one you
know maybe i i'm a little disappointed
that i didn't get more winning chances
but it was i think it was a pretty
awesome game plenty of stuff to analyze
and uh i'm happy to play games like that
well with representatives like you
defending the us chess cause we're happy
to watch you play good luck in the rest
of your game thank you very much
appreciate it grand master daniel
naradiski one of the future stars of
well current stars of u.s chess uh jen
and yaz with with
with young men like this representing us
uh we got a bright future ahead for us
chess back to you
agreed all around and i like dan daniels
attitude especially i mean he recognized
his position was desperate sometimes
desperate positions call for desperate
measures and that's where he came up
with this king f3 g4 trying to mix it up
and just that's what chess you have to
do is try to cause as many problems for
your opponent as you possibly can and
josh stumbled against this
tenacity of refusing to roll over so
very very nice game by danya to save a
difficult position
are we done are there any other games we
have all of the results in fantastic
tell us how the knee behind sky game was
a draw okay and we've also got yeah the
grave
um lenderman game they did shake hands
that game's a draw as well so okay i
think we are going to hear from graham
in just a bit all right so at the moment
in the women's section we have two uh
players with perfect scores
arena
and sabine at 2-0
and in the men's section
um
we have a couple one and a half yeah so
the fisher pie is no longer in play for
the us chest championship exactly and
who are the leaders in our men's
sections with one and a half
well we've got ray robson right right
and um lenderman so both of the players
that won yesterday
and then also
yeah that's it right that's it so two
players at one and a half and two
players said two
very good
and
and uh we'll have our guest studio guest
soon i have on our screen the game
between lenderman and timor and this was
the crazy
uh game where the queen sacrifices start
started being played
after e4 e5 and and i was thinking that
h2 h3 with the idea of g4 in e5 is how
we're going to question
those players when they join maurice
well actually um we are going to uh
to close the show okay and we are
encouraging you all to check out us
chess champs for additional information
and we're going to be back tomorrow for
some more exciting action here at the
championships in u.s women's but uh what
a final comment from maurice first
indeed we saw some tremendous fighting
chess today jen what's interesting is
the game yesterday we were really uh not
happy with the way the one and two seed
on the men's side played but today they
gave us some tremendous fighting chess
games lasting well into the next time
control
down to almost nothing left on the board
the kind of stuff we all love to see so
that was fantastic on the women's side
we saw lots of victories as we expect
and still some perfect scores so an
exciting situation now just starting to
to get going of course only two rounds
in the books with another nine to go in
the men's side and another seven to go
on the women's side so a lot of action a
lot of interesting games a lot of
entertainment still ahead here in saint
louis at the u.s chess championships
back to you guys
that's right don't mess around
be with us tomorrow i'm jennifer jihadi
signing out for grandmaster's maurice
ashley and yasser sarawan here in the
chess capital of america
you